il y a moins d'une heure la ville de
Tours dévoilait le compte à rebours qui
sera installé sur le parvis de l'hôtel
de ville et qui va égrainer les jours
qu'il nous reste avant le lancement de
la Coupe du monde de rugby d'autres
animations sont également prévues pour
vivre cet événement sportif mondial les
profiter de l'accueil à Tours de
l'équipe d'Irlande on en parle avec
notre invité du jour
Eric Thomas bonjour vous êtes adjoint au
sport à la ville de Tours et vous êtes
justement devant ce compteur alors à son
jour du lancement de la compétition
officielle le 8 septembre prochain la
Ville de Tours vient de révéler le
programme des réjouissances qu'elle
prévoit et ça commence avec la création
de quatre fans avec écran géant pour les
amateurs d'Ovalie
exactement
le rugby est un sport populaire il faut
qu'il le reste il faut que les tours en
gel est toujours enjaux puissent
bénéficier de ces grands matchs on a on
a pas la chance d'avoir deux matchs à
Tours on a la chance d'avoir l'équipe
numéro 1 l'équipe d'Irlande qui va
arriver fin août qui va repartir début
octobre voilà l'idée c'est de profiter
de leur présence et puis c'est aussi de
profiter des grands matchs à commencer
par le premier grand match d'ouverture
le 8 septembre France Nouvelle-Zélande à
donner à Londres l'antre du rugby
touranjo entrée gratuite évidemment
puisque il faut que maximum de tout
rangé et tout en jeu puisse profiter de
ces événements partage cette Coupe du
Monde et envie de voir de rencontrer
d'échanger avec les Irlandais pour
participer aussi à ce moment sportif
mondial alors pour l'instant un seul
entraînement de l'équipe d'Irlande sera
ouvert au public expliquer nous où
est-ce que ça va se passer et comment
les chanceux pourront-ils y assister
alors un seul entraînement on espère on
essaie de négocier d'eux mais un sur ça
sera la vallée du Cher évidemment vous
savez que la vallée du Cher a accueilli
un crunch un franc Angleterre féminin
U20 il n'y a pas si longtemps avec un
succès populaire incroyable puisqu'on a
fait pratiquement 6000 spectateurs pour
ce match donc on attend au moins autant
de tout ranger et de tout rangeau pour
pour cet entraînement qui sera lui aussi
gratuit on pourra voir les Irlandais
l'équipe favorite
avec la France
cet entraînement est-ce que vous croisez
en quart de finale est-ce que vous avez
déjà une date à nous annoncer pour cet
entraînement public
pas encore
c'est en discussion
on sait qu'on va accueillir
officiellement les Irlandais le 2
septembre ça c'est l'accueil officiel
mais la date est encore en négociation
avec avec la délégation irlandaise on
aimerait bien qu'elle se fasse
évidemment après la rentrée scolaire
alors il y aura également le stade de la
chambreerie qui servira on le sait de
terrain d'entraînement au joueur du 15
du Trèfle il sera d'ailleurs inauguré le
5 juillet prochain en présence d'une
délégation irlandaise et vous serez
également de la partie Monsieur Thomas
c'est un équipement exceptionnel
rendez-vous compte on a posé la première
pierre en juillet 2022 et on va
l'inaugurer le 5 juillet 2023 c'est un
exploit aujourd'hui construire un
bâtiment de 1200 mètres carrés avec une
salle de musculation de 300 mètres
carrés le top du top de l'équipement
huit vestiaires des bureaux des
vestiaires d'arbitre un terrain un
terrain de rugby aux normes
international voilà félicitations à
toutes les équipes de la ville qui ont
travaillé d'arrache-pied pour livrer cet
équipement aux entreprises prestataires
pour livrer ces équipements dans les
temps la pression était forte et le défi
est réalisé laissait transformer
je pense que on aura une très très belle
inauguration le 5 juillet et puis
surtout avec de beaux ambassadeurs
l'équipe d'Irlande évidemment mais cet
équipement il va profiter au gamin et
aux gamines qui vont venir jouer au
rugby à la chambreerie pour des
générations et générations donc c'est
l'héritage de cette Coupe du Monde c'est
l'héritage que la ville de Tours va
transmettre à lui est au rugby dernière
date très très vite le 10 septembre à
l'occasion de la prochaine édition tour
en fait et bien le rugby est l'Irlande
seront également mis en valeur
exactement chaque année c'est la grande
rentrée du sport et des associations
avec tout en fait anciennement sport
ouvertes tous les tours en gel et tout
en jour pourront à cette occasion
évidemment célébrer le rugby célébrer la
Coupe du Monde et puis venir dire à nos
amis irlandais qu'ils sont les bienvenus
et leurs réserver le meilleur accueil
possible merci merci beaucoup Eric
Thomas pour toutes vos précisions et
merci à Clémence d'Osca qui vous
accompagne et qui a rendu ce duplex
possible